imagine you're in charge of government
and you decide that it's time to take
your existing jungle Council and you're
going to switch it over to STV one of
the things that is an option is because
STV requires there to be more than one
representative per range you can either
triple at a bare minimum or quintuple
the number of politicians you have which
might be something you want to do but
there are many good reasons why you
might not want to do that here's a more
reasonable way in which you actually
switch over a country to STV here's a
map of our current electoral ranges each
of which sends one representative so
step one is we're going to get rid of
all of these ranges and we're going to
redraw the boundary so instead of
everybody getting elected from one range
we're going to draw ranges that have
five representatives in each now if
local representation means anything
you're probably going to want to try to
draw these boundaries in meaningful ways
in your country so they follow natural
boundaries or they follow town
boundaries or historical boundaries
you're going to want to try to match
those as close as you reasonably can but
an important thing to realize is that
you do not have to have all of the
ranges be the exact same size in terms
of Representatives so in the bottom
corner of the map over here you can see
we have a kind of animal city and so
what you can do is instead of trying to
divide that up into a bunch of five
representative ranges you can take it
and say no we're just going to cut it
into two there's the North half of the
city and there's the South half of the
city and that's two ranges with nine
representatives each now you may be
asking why don't you just make it one
range with eighteen representatives the
answer is there's a kind of trade-off
for making larger ranges the larger the
ranges you have a benefit in that it is
going to be more representative of the
local population so in theory arranged
with 40 or 50 representatives would be
even better than a range with just say
five but the price you pay for a bigger
range is a more complicated election
because if there are say nine seats open
you're probably going to have at least
twenty candidates running so if you
actually have a range that has eighteen
seats available you're probably looking
at an election that's going to have 40
or 50 candidates which is a little bit
beyond what you can expect a reasonable
person to be able to distinguish among
even eighteen is getting a bit up there
which is what
reasonable STV systems allow you to just
list your favorites as far as you care
to go say one through five and then just
not fill in the ballot anymore because
you don't care anymore
now the flipside to this problem is when
you have a very sparsely populated
region as we have in the upper left here
many countries have their own version of
flyover regions where the population is
widely widely distributed and very thin
in that case trying to draw a range that
had five representatives might just be
comically large so big as to just make a
mockery of the very notion that these
representatives are local in any sense
of that word so if you have a very
sparsely populated region you can have a
smaller range as well so in this case
we're going to make one range with three
representatives in the corner now as
before the advantage you get with a
smaller election is that it is easier to
follow they're going to be fewer
candidates running however smaller
ranges are much more susceptible to
intentional gerrymandering and three is
at about that number if your country is
switching over to single transferable
vote and it wants to make all of the
ranges three you should be very
suspicious because three is gerrymander
Abul it is going to be less
proportionate than a larger ring it is
acceptable under certain reasonable
circumstances but it definitely
shouldn't be the standard five should
really be the minimum and nine should
probably be the maximum